dimanche votre Ministre de la culture
s'est cru autorisé à se mêler de la
ligne éditoriale d'un journal français
média privé et à s'exprimer publiquement
sur le recrutement de l'un de ses
journalistes que la ministre de la
Culture décerne des certificats de
valeurs républicaine au journaux
français et particulièrement inquiétant
pour la démocratie la ministre de la
Culture et votre gouvernement devrait
avoir comme premier principe la défense
de la liberté de la presse sans que
celle-ci est à subir la pression du
pouvoir en place ce n'est pas la
première fois que Madame Abdoul Malak
exerce des pressions voir des menaces
contre un organe de presse elle a menacé
les chaînes de télévision cnews et C8 là
encore media privé de ne pas voir leur
licence renouvelée et de les priver de
leurs fréquence elle sort régulièrement
de son domaine de responsabilité de son
devoir de réserve pour s'attaquer à des
médias à des animateurs et à des
journalistes envers lesquels elle cache
mal sa détestation une fois n'est pas
coutume mes oreilles ont saignaient en
écoutant votre question madame réputé
mes oreilles ont saignées madame la
députée quand j'ai cru comprendre que
vous étiez sur le point nous donner une
leçon de pluralisme et d'indépendance de
la presse
[Musique]
mes oreilles enseignées parce que Madame
la député jusqu'à il y a 15 jours votre
parti politique dirigé par votre
président de groupe Madame Le Pen
censuré boycotter une chaîne
d'information BFM TV parce qu'elle avait
l'autre cuit danse de faire un choix
éditorial qui consistait recruter un
journaliste de l'émission quotidien mes
oreilles enseignées madame la députée
quand je me suis souvenu qu'en 2019
c'était le chiffre est un mec quand même
éloquent 28 sociétés de journalistes
excusez du peu qui épinglé les principes
de votre les pratiques de votre partie
après comme Le Pen est décrété que des
journalistes n'en étaient pas ciblant
ainsi quotidien excusez du peu l'AFP
excusez du feu Radio France le monde ou
France 24 je crois madame la députée que
ces médias sont des médias d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont tous soutenus
par les pouvoirs publics plus que ça
madame la député ils sont chéris ils
sont protégés parce que même quand ils
racontent des choses qui ne nous
plaisent pas même quand elle est
journaliste qui ne nous reviennent pas
ils font leur travail de journaliste et
c'est l'honneur de la démocratie que de
les respecter les leçons garde les